[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers einen
guten Montagabend ihnen allen so
ziemlich das Allerletzte was wir gerade
noch brauchen könnten ist eine globale
Finanzkrise so weit sind wir nicht aber
die Nervosität an den Finanzmärkten ist
mit Händen zu greifen die Angst der
Anleger ihre Investments zu verlieren
spürbar die Bank die einst die
industrielle Basis der Schweiz
finanziert hat das Eisenbahnnetz und den
Gotthardtunnel ist am Ende und mit ihr
ein nationales Symbol so wie damals als
die Flugzeuge der Swissair rund um den
Globus festhängen weil keiner mehr mit
einer Pleite Unternehmen Geschäfte
machen wollte so läuft es jetzt bei der
Kredit Swiss der schwindelerregende
skandalabstieg eines Geldhauses mit der
notübernahme durch die hauptkonkurrentin
und mit Steuer milliarden sollen jetzt
noch gravierendere Folgen verhindert
werden ob das gelingt
Zürich Paradeplatz das Zuhause der
angeschlagenen Credit Suisse hier war
man stolz in der Finanzkrise vor 15
Jahren keine Staatshilfe gebraucht zu
haben doch in den vergangenen Jahren
häuften sich Managementfehler die
Schweizer Banker versenkten Milliarden
unter anderem im investment-geschäft
also beispielsweise war die Bank
beteiligt an Geschäften mit Autokraten
und und kriminellen was die Swiss leaks
aufgezeigt haben vor einigen Jahren sie
hat von Pleiten eines Hedgefonds von der
Pleite eines Hedgefonds hat sie einige
Verluste davon getragen aber bei der
greensill Pleite mit hohen Beträgen
involviert das heißt eine ganze Serie
von Problemen das zeigt auch der Blick
auf die Zahlen
2022 machte die Credit Suisse einen
Verlust von rund 7,3 Milliarden Franken
was in etwa der gleichen Summe in Euro
entsprechen die Kunden verließen in
Scharen die Bank allein im vierten
Quartal zogen sie rund 111 Milliarden
Frank en als Vermögen ab hat die
Schweizer Banken auf sich zu spät
reagiert
sie haben offenkundig die ganze Sache zu
lange laufen lassen mich genug gedrängt
auf Reform in der Bank auf Veränderung
Geschäftsmodell die Frage ist ob das die
Aufgabe der Bankenaufsicht ist oder ob
man eben auch wirtschaftlich scheitern
darf mit Blick auf die hohen
systemischen Risiken werden aber sehr
viele sagen die Banken auf sich hätte
früher einschreiten müssen die
Rettungsaktion von Schweizer Regierungen
und Nationalbank am Wochenende
beispiellos die UBS die andere Großbank
in der Schweiz muss die Credit Suisse
übernehmen notgedrungen der Schweizer
Staat gibt liquiditätszusagen in
dreistelliger Milliarden Höhe die
Aktionäre verlieren ihr Mitsprache recht
alles um den Schweizer Bankenplatz zu
retten
Schweizer bankkultur ist natürlich ein
heiliges national gut von daher ist ganz
klar sie werden es in den Griff bekommen
aber die neue Bank die UBS ist so groß
wer soll die noch retten wenn was
passiert das Schweizer Banken Beben
sorgt für Unruhe auf den Finanzmärkten
die Frage in Frankfurt Banken wie gut
sind die Banken in Deutschland und den
Rest der Eurozone aufgestellt rot eine
neue Finanzkrise
die Maßnahmen der Aufsicht und der
Notenbank in USA und auch in der Schweiz
haben die Märkte schon sehr beruhigt
wir haben ja keine Bankenkrise wir haben
eine Situation des Banken Stress auch
die icd-präsidentin bekräftigt heute in
Brüssel die Eurozone seit den jüngsten
Turbulenzen gewachsen
wir glauben dass der Bankensektor im
Euroraum widerstandsfähig ist mit
starken Kapital und
liquiditätspositionen und ich wiederhole
es gerne noch einmal in jedem Fall
stehen wir bereit um Liquiditätshilfen
für das Finanzsystem des Euroraums
bereitzustellen
das Signal ist klar die Märkte sollen
beruhigt werden damit sich die
Finanzkrise von 2008 nicht wiederholt
Peer Steinbrück war in der großen
Finanzkrise 2008 Bundesfinanzminister
und ist jetzt bei uns genannter
Steinbrück und nahm der Sievers wie sehr
fühlen sie sich denn jetzt gerade wieder
an das erinnert was sie damals zu
managen hatten
ja wie heißt die politische lehrformel
sowohl als auch also bezogen auf die
Nervosität die besteht die
Unsicherheiten und des innerhalb noch
voll vielen Einlegern fühle ich mich
erinnert aber freimütig gesagt die
konkrete Lage ist keineswegs so
dramatisch wie
2018/209 und ich habe an sich angesichts
der heutigen Kommentare auch ein
bisschen in Eindruck dass man vor über
Dramatisierung und damit eine weiteren
Verunsicherung von vielen kundenanlegern
und Investoren sehr vorsichtig sein
sollte sie sagen es ist nicht wieder so
dramatisch wie damals es gibt
tatsächlich ja jetzt auch einige
Sicherungen im Bankensystem und dennoch
geht die Sorge um wie kann denn das sein
dass wir Unfähigkeit und Gier einzelner
Banken und Bankmanager einfach nicht in
den Griff zu bekommen zu scheinen
die gibt es und es gibt auch nach wie
vor Leute die ordentlich zocken aber die
gibt es nicht nur in Bankenbereich
sondern die gibt es auch anderswo und
das sind teilweise auch Investoren und
Anleger wie Sie und ich auch selbst aber
vor dem Hintergrund der damaligen Krise
muss man feststellen der Ausgangspunkt
sind drei spezifische amerikanische
Banken eher mittlerer Größenordnung die
sich im Anleihenmarkt verspekuliert
haben und eine europäische Bank wie die
kreditismus die aber schon seit drei
oder vier Jahren als ein ziemlich
unsicherer Kantonist gilt und sehr viel
falsch gemacht hat und zwar nicht nur
falsch gemacht hat im Sinne von viel
Entscheidungen sondern ja auch in Sachen
Geldwäsche engagiert war Korruption
Besitzung eigene Leute also in der Tat
und der moralischen Gesichtspunkten und
wahrscheinlich schwer als das in einer
ausgesprochen schwierigen Lage war die
keineswegs das Vertrauen der Anleger
verdiente ja jetzt hat man allerdings
auch gesagt das bleibt in den USA ich
glaube sie selbstverständlich haben es
auch gesagt das ist einfach nur ein
amerikanisches Problem wir wissen
mittlerweile besser dass es genau das
nicht war wir sehen so ein bisschen dann
doch wieder dieselben ja wie soll ich
sagen dieses dieselben Geschichten hohes
Risiko hohe Boni und am Ende zahlen die
Steuerzahler was muss denn passieren
damit das tatsächlich stoppt ja das mit
den Boni gilt das gilt insbesondere bei
der Kredit fest wenn man sich vorstellt
dass die in den letzten 10 Jahren
ungefähr 30 Milliarden an Franken an
Bruni ausgezahlt haben aber in denselben
10 Jahren ich glaube zweiter bis 3
Milliarden Verluste gemacht haben aber
es ist ja nicht so dass nichts passiert
ist also es sind Regularien eingezogen
worden die liquiditätsprossen besser ist
ist eine größere
kernkapitalanforderungen veranlasst
worden wir haben es mit einer
europäischen Bankenaufsicht zu tun wir
haben es auch mit einem von den Banken
noch und zu reichen aber immerhin an
finanzierten
abschirmungsfond zu tun also vieles ist
in Gang gekommen weshalb ich glaube die
Bezeichnung richtig ist die europäischen
Banken die deutschen Banken sind sehr
viel Widerstand sfähige und robuster
aufgestellt als vor 15 Jahren jetzt höre
ich ja Steinbrück auch bei ihnen gerade
wieder heraus wie wichtig es ist nicht
in Nervosität zu verfallen also
Psychologie ist das Stichwort bei der
ganzen Geschichte ist sehr gefragt
angesichts Hyper nervöser Märkte wie wir
sie haben es gibt halt so Momente an die
wird man sich als Finanzminister und
eben auch als Bankkunde immer erinnern
wir können uns mal ihren ja anschauen
wir sagen den SparerInnen und Sparern
dass ihre Einlagen sicher sind auch
dafür steht die Bundesregierung ein
ja ich möchte gerne unterstreichen des
in der Tat in der gemeinsamen
Verantwortung die wir in der
Bundesregierung fühlen wir dafür Sorge
tragen wollen dass die sparen und Sparer
in Deutschland nicht befürchten müssen
einen Euro ihrer Einlagen zu verlieren
ja das war Herr Steinbrück quasi ihre
Besucher mit Worten was können wir
lernen von damals für heute von diesem
Auftritt
dass die Politik nichts verharmlosen
soll dass sie nichts kleinreden soll
dass sie den Bürgern und Bürgern reinen
Wein anschenken soll aber ebenfalls auch
handlungsfähig sein soll um
sicherheits-sicherheit
ja Lehen zu ziehen und dafür Sorge zu
tragen dass im Zusammenwirken von
Bundesregierung
Bankenaufsicht Europäische Zentralbank
und anderen Partnern ein gutes
Krisenmanagement entwickelt wird und der
Bank auf sich ist ab zu verlangen dass
sie bereits prophylaktisch sehr viel
stärker auf das guckt das möglicherweise
an Risiko hochpoppen kann brauchen wir
bald so einen Auftritt auch von Scholz
und Lindner man hört vom Bundeskanzler
ja so ähnliche Worte aber bislang immer
nur wir Regierungssprecher versucht der
quasi gerade so eine Art Mittelding oder
wie sehen Sie das ja ja ich habe ihn so
verstanden dass er eine solche
Garantie mindestens in einer gewissen
Vergleichbarkeit gegenüber 2008 auch
angedeutet hat da steckt natürlich viel
Technologie dahinter die ich für richtig
erachte damit Anleger nicht weiter
nervös werden oder Investoren dasselbe
hat Präsident beiden in den USA gemacht
und an diesem Wochenende ist natürlich
in der Schweiz ein ziemlich striktes
Krisenmanagement entgangen gekommen dass
jedenfalls auf absehbare Zeit ja auch
dazu führt dass die Märkte sich etwas
beruhigt haben ja die Schweiz hat da
Feuerwehr gespielt oder spielt immer
noch Feuerwehr die Schweizer Regierung
mit unfassbaren Mengen von Steuergeldern
also genau mit dem was wir eigentlich
nicht mehr wollten jetzt erleben wir die
neue Züricher Zeitung schreibt heute ein
Zombie ist weg ein Monster entsteht
diese neue superbank die da in der
Schweiz entsteht ist in der Bilanzsumme
doppelt so groß wie das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt der Schweiz das
heißt die Regierung ist doch nun
wirklich durch diese Bank erpressbar
geworden denn diese Bank ist tatsächlich
zu back to fail oder
ja in der Tat die hat eine Bilanzsumme
von über 1.500 Milliarden also über 1,5
Billionen Franken und ist in der Tat ein
Koloss auf der anderen Seite sind diese
Schweizer Banken schon immer so stark
international aufgestellt das eigentlich
ihre Aktivitäten und damit auch ihre
Bilanzsumme ihr Vermögen über ihre
Aktivitäten weit über die nationalen
Grenzen hinausgewiesen hat aber man muss
auf der anderen Seite schon die Frage
stellen ob es nicht an der Zeit ist dass
diese Bilanz deutlich stabilisiert und
möglicherweise auch verkürzt wird um von
diesem Volumen herunter zu kommen Angela
Merkel hat 2008 gesagt sie gehe jeden
Abend mit der Sorge schlafen welcher
Banker am nächsten Morgen um Geld bitten
würde wie gut schlafen sie aktuell
so wie auch in den Wochen davor aber
richtig ist wir stellen fest dass in der
ohnehin sehr für unsicher hätten
Landschaft über die Pandemie über die
Inflation über den schrecklichen Krieg
in der Ukraine über die Erfahrung mit
Lieferketten Problemen natürlich die
nervositäten doch sehr viel deutlicher
gewachsen sind und auch über den
jetzigen Anlass von einigen Krisen
Fällen von Banken deutlich hinausgeht
und das spricht den Markt insgesamt sagt
er Steinbrück ehemals
Bundesfinanzminister Steinbrück vielen
Dank für das Gespräch heute abend ich
danke
und das Interview haben wir kurz vor
dieser Sendung aufgezeichnet wenn sich
alle beeilen um sicherzustellen dass
alles in Ordnung ist dann sind die Dinge
meist nicht in Ordnung das sagt ein
Analyst heute zur Aktion mehrerer
Notenbanken vergangenen Nacht die die
Versorgung mit dem Dollar verbessern
soll die Stabilität des Finanzsystems
stärken so ganz überzeugt sind die
Börsen nicht die Aktie der Credit Suisse
sagte um 56 Prozent ab Valerie Haller
guten Abend nach Frankfurt wie sieht's
generell aus an den Börsen ja die
Übernahme der Credit Suisse hat schon
viel Stress aus dem System genommen kein
unkontrollierter Zusammenbruch man
wertet das hier schon so die Kuh die ist
erstmal vom Eis entsprechend sieht es an
der Börse aus der DAX beendet den Tag
mit einem ordentlichen Plus von rund
einem Prozent auch die Bankenwerte haben
sich etwas erholt aber deutlich
langsamer und das ist schon ein Hinweis
darauf dass man sich fragt was da
vielleicht noch kommt also Beruhigung ja
Entwarnung nein aber was das Gelingen
dieser historischen Megafusion da in der
Schweiz angeht die ja keine der beiden
Banken wollte da gibt es noch einige
Fragezeichen oder ja weil der
Zusammenschluss war ja schon eine
ziemliche Hauruck-Aktion unter den
Diktat der Schweizer Regierung unklar ob
das überhaupt juristisch wasserdicht ist
und ob da nicht noch klagen Nachkommen
auch zeigt die Geschichte das ist nicht
immer gut geht wenn sich zwei Riesen
zusammen tun die UBS läuft Gefahr selbst
zum Sanierungsfall zu werden denn zwei
große Systeme miteinander zu
verschmelzen das braucht Zeit und das
ist auch meist sehr sehr teuer ja und
was ist überhaupt mit dem Erbe der
Kredit Swiss sie hat Anleihen im
milliardenwert herausgegeben wer hat wie
viele davon im Depot keiner weißes
immerhin stehen 16 Milliarden Euro im
Feuer ein ganz schöner Brocken der vom
System erstmal verdaut werden muss also
noch einige Fragen und viel Raum für
mögliche Überraschungen Valerie hat sich
in Dank nach Frankfurt für diese Analyse
und so viel zunächst heute Abend zu
diesem Thema
die französische Regierung hat ein
Misstrauensvotum im Parlament
überstanden die geplante Rentenreform
das zentrale Projekt der zweiten
Amtszeit von Präsident Emmanuel macron
ist damit beschlossen allerdings ohne
dass die Nationalversammlung darüber
endgültig abgestimmt hätte macron und
seine Regierung haben Sie per
sonderbefugnis durchgesetzt auf den
Straßen bei unseren Nachbarn ist immer
noch viel Misstrauen zu spüren Anna
Warsberg ist in Paris
die erforderliche Mehrheit ist nicht
erreicht das Misstrauensvotum ist nicht
angenommen die linke Opposition hat ihre
Antwort darauf schon parat wir machen
weiter und wir treffen uns auf der
Straße steht auf ihren Schildern die
Regierung darf bleiben die Rentenreform
ist beschlossen aber das politische
Ringen geht weiter ich bin erleichtert
dass der Misstrauensantrag nicht
angenommen wurde wie es einige Leute
vermuten ließen das ist eine Niederlage
für die Opposition
die Premierministerin hat den Artikel
49,3 gezogen weil sie wusste dass sie
bei der Abstimmung über die Rentenreform
verlieren würde und das bei einer
Ohrfeige für die Franzosen werden
das Ergebnis des zweiten
Misstrauensvotums scheint nur noch
Formsache die Regierung bleibt sitzen
der Rest ist schon wie angekündigt auf
der Straße bei den Menschen die ihre Wut
über die Regierung rauslassen
[Applaus]
am Wochenende wurden die Proteste in
ganz Frankreich immer radikaler mit
einer macron-puppe auf dem
Scheiterhaufen
Molotow Cocktails in Marseille
und Feuer im Rathaus von Lyon
viele sehr viele Franzosen wollen auch
nach heute nicht akzeptieren das
Präsident macron eine Reform die ihre
Rente betrifft ohne Abstimmung
durchdrücken kann
ich habe damit gerechnet also ich bin
auf jeden Fall nicht enttäuscht diese
Leute können mich nicht mehr enttäuschen
morgen sind wir wieder auf der Straße
der Kampf geht weiter
werden wir auch mit Gewalt vorgehen
es könnten weitere ungemütliche Tage in
Frankreich werden Präsident macron hat
sich zu alldem noch nicht geäußert auf
der Straße greift an diesem Abend die
Staatsgewalt durch
das klingt einigermaßen dramatisch wir
gehen live nach Paris zu einer Arendt
eine guten Abend die Reform ist durch
haben wir verstanden wie geht's jetzt
weiter mit dem Protesten dagegen
ja die misstrauensanträge hier im
Parlament also in der assemblen National
wo wir gerade stehen die sind
überstanden und das Rentengesetz ist
damit beschlossen aber wie eben im
Beitrag gesehen das bedeutet nicht in
ein Ende der Proteste unmittelbar nach
der Entscheidung haben sich die Menschen
zu spontanen Demonstrationen
zusammengefunden in Paris und in anderen
Städten und selbst durch die dichten
Gemäuer konnten wir die Sirenen der
Polizei hören die Wut davon ist
auszugehen die wird in den kommenden
Tagen noch lauter auf die Straßen
getragen werden für Donnerstag ist eine
Großdemo angekündigt es ist zu erwarten
dass die Streiks weitergehen denn die
Mehrheit im Land die lehnt diese Reform
ab und die Art wie sie nun umgesetzt
wurde macrons Alleingang sozusagen das
hat die Französinnen und Franzosen wohl
auf lange Sicht verprellt das
Interessante ist ja auch wie knapp das
ganze ausgegangen ist das war ja
wirklich haarscharf dass die Regierung
von Präsident macron dieses
Misstrauensvotum überstehen konnte wie
geschwächt ist denn der Präsident jetzt
ja er ist erheblich geschwächt würde ich
sagen mit der Entscheidung die
Rentenreform an die Vertrauensfrage zu
knüpfen hat er sich auf einen schmalen
Grad begeben der Präsident macron dessen
Lager ja im Parlament keine eigene
Mehrheit hat hat darauf spekuliert dass
die Konservativen an seiner Seite stehen
und das ist gerade mal und sehr knapp
gut gegangen aber es zeigt wie es in wie
schwer es für ihn in Zukunft sein wird
politische Projekte umzusetzen also
Mitstreiter für seine Vorhaben zu finden
die Opposition vom linken sowie vom
extremen rechten Rand die treibt ihn im
Grunde vor sich her und für macron der
ja einst angetreten ist das Land zu
reformieren der ist befindet sich im
Grunde in einer politischen Sackgasse
schwierige Zeiten in Frankreich eine
Aare in Paris ganz herzlichen Dank für
diese Informationen heute Abend und
damit hier bei uns in der Sendung jetzt
in die Weltpolitik und mit Johanna und
zu einem Treffen das international viel
Aufmerksamkeit bekommt denn erstmals
seit Beginn des zwischen angriffskriegs
gegen die Ukraine ist der chinesische
Staatschef Schi zu einem Besuch nach
Moskau gereist dort wurde er vom
russischen Präsidenten Putin als Freund
begrüßt und beide unterstrichen ihre
Einigkeit neben einer Vertiefung der
Handelsbeziehungen soll es bei dem
dreitägigen Staatsbesuch auch um den
Krieg in der Ukraine gehen china hat
diesen bisher nicht verurteilt
die Außen und verteidigungsministerinnen
und Minister der Europäischen Union
haben beschlossen der Ukraine in den
nächsten 12 Monaten eine Million
Artillerie Geschosse zu liefern einen
Teil davon sollen die Mitgliedstaaten
aus eigenen Beständen liefern auch eine
gemeinsame Bestellung neuer Munition ist
vorgesehen insgesamt stellt die EU dafür
rund 2 Milliarden Euro bereit
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
betonte die Lieferungen müssten schnell
erfolgen
um in der Türkei und in Syrien nach der
verheerenden
Erdbebenkatastrophe den Wiederaufbau zu
unterstützen wurden den beiden Ländern
auf einer internationalen Geberkonferenz
7 Milliarden Euro zugesagt allein die
EU-Kommission kündigte eine Milliarde
für die Türkei und 108 Millionen Euro
für Syrien an bei den schweren Erdbeben
vor sechs Wochen starben mehr als 50.000
Menschen und Millionen wurden obdachlos
künstliche Intelligenz gewinnt mehr und
mehr an Bedeutung nun hat sich der
Deutsche Ethikrat zu möglichen Risiken
von KI geäußert und in einer
Stellungnahme erklärt dass diese den
Menschen nicht ersetzen dürfen
künstliche Intelligenz müssen
menschliche Entfaltung erweitern und
dürfe sie nicht vermindern sagte die
Vorsitzende des Deutschen Ethikrates
büks im Medizinbereich sei der Einsatz
von KI zum Beispiel durchaus sinnvoll
allerdings dürfe dies nicht zu einem
Kompetenzverlust bei Ärztinnen und
Ärzten führen
es ist die letzte Warnung unsere Zeit
läuft ab wenn wir nicht jetzt drastisch
Umsteuern lässt sich die
Klimakatastrophe nicht mehr aufhalten
eine Katastrophe die besonders stark bis
zu 3,6 Milliarden Menschen in Gefahr
bringt das ist fast die Hälfte der
Weltbevölkerung diese Zahlen hat der
Weltklimarat uns heute ins Stammbuch
geschrieben ein Gremium von 195 Ländern
das Daten ausgewertet und
zusammengefasst hat die von tausenden
Experten stammen also so etwas wie das
gesammelte Wissen der Wissenschaft
so dystopisch sich diese Mahnung liest
der Bericht will viel mehr sein nämlich
ein
überlebensleitfaden für die Menschheit
wie ist der UNO Generalsekretär heute
ausdrückte denn wir können eine
lebenswerte Zukunft für alle sichern
wenn wir jetzt handeln Elisa Miebach und
Brigitte
die Männer vom Wasserwirtschaftsamt
München messen mit Sorge den aktuellen
Grundwasserstand zu wenig Regen oder
Schnee auch diesen Winter konnte sich
der Pegel nicht erholen hier in Haar
steht das Wasser einen Meter fünfzig
unter dem Mittelwert ein Minusrekord und
wohl auch ein Indiz dass der Klimawandel
bei uns voranschreitet also wir haben
jetzt in den letzten 12 Jahren zehn
Jahre gehabt wo wir weniger
niederschlagen Niederschläge gehabt
haben also weniger Regen als wir das
normalerweise haben was bedeutet dass
wir pro Quadratmeter 200 Liter weniger
Wasser zur Verfügung haben in Interlaken
in der Schweiz stellt der Welt Klimarat
heute die weltweit größte Studie zum
Klimawandel vor die den aktuellen Stand
der Wissenschaft zusammenfasst der
Bericht sagt klar die globale Erwärmung
ist menschengemacht schon jetzt hat sich
die Erde um 1,1 Grad erwärmt und mit
jedem zusätzlichen zehn Grad
verschlimmern sich die Schäden es
bräuchte drei bis sechs Mal mehr
Investitionen als bisher um die
Klimakrise nicht komplett eskalieren zu
lassen Geld ist momentan oder ist global
gesehen vorhanden ausreichend fanden es
wird noch nicht ausreichend in
Klimaschutz und klimawandelanpassungen
gesteckt wir sprechen zwar viel über die
Finanzierung von erneuerbaren Energien
meintwegen trotzdem sind die
Investitionen momentan noch größer in
die ganz traditionelle
kohlenstoffbasierte Industrie kurz
gesagt es braucht Maßnahmen an allen
Fronten alles überall sofort
Ulrich Meck aus Günzburg gibt schon seit
30 Jahren alles für den Klimaschutz sein
Lebenswerk aus Ackerland hat er wieder
ein Moor gemacht denn nicht nur im
Verkehr und beim Strom können massiv
Treibhausgase eingespart werden die
Grundstoffe der treibhausgasse also zum
Beispiel der Kohlenstoff wird in den
Pflanzenteilen die im Ohr den
draufbilden gespeichert und wenn ich
jetzt einen entweder nur wieder nass
mache dann reagiert es so schnell dass
es uns eigentlich ein bisschen Zeit
verschafft in Zusammenhang mit der
Klimakrise Christian Meyer hat im Sumpf
nun eine Wasser Büffelherde stehen er
hofft mit dem Moor auch die Trockenheit
auf seinem benachbarten Feldern besser
in den Griff zu kriegen das nimmt
überschüssigen Regen auf kühlt an
Hitzetagen und durchfeuchtet den Boden
bis runter zum Grundwasser
wieder anheben dann haben wir hier
wirklich die Möglichkeit noch an Ertrag
von der Flächen runterzubringen weil wir
brauchen um Gras oder Getreide zum
Wachsen braucht halt Wasser und Schicht
und wenn beides weg ist dann wächst halt
nichts mehr
Lösungen in der Klimakrise gibt es also
viele Orts jetzt geht es darum sie im
großen Stil umzusetzen
heute vor 20 Jahren es ist kurz nach 4
Uhr in der Nacht bei uns als
US-Präsident George W Bush im Fernsehen
erscheint und eine Entscheidung bekannt
gibt die nicht nur die USA bis heute
verfolgt mein verlustanger
Operation Rocky freedom der Einmarsch
von US-Truppen im Irak die sogenannte
Koalition der Willigen auf einer Mission
die auf der falschen Behauptung basierte
Iraks Diktator aus Adam Hussein habe
Massenvernichtungswaffen es war eine der
folgenschwersten Fehlentscheidungen des
21 jahrhunderts eine die Amerika in
vielen Teilen der Welt seine
Glaubwürdigkeit kostete der Tag an dem
eine super macht im Namen der Demokratie
das Völkerrecht brach
die schlimmsten Folgen hatte der Krieg
im Irak selbst wo hunderttausende
Zivilisten deshalb ihr Leben verloren
der nissurplatz in Bagdad justim
mohammed war zur falschen Zeit an diesem
Ort die Narbe lässt ihn niemals
vergessen Jesse Mohammed wurde in den
Kopf geschossen von einem amerikanischen
Söldner ein Massaker auf offener Straße
17 Menschen wurden an diesem Tag getötet
Söldner die eigentlich US-Diplomaten
schützen sollten töteten unschuldige
Märtyrer verletzte wer wird sie
entschädigen Millionen sind bis heute
von der Invasion der Amerikaner
betroffen
manchmal tue sein Kopf so weh dass er
ihn am liebsten abreißen und Ablegen
würde die Invasion der Amerikaner
änderte sein Leben änderte das ganze
Land es war das Ende von Diktator Saddam
Hussein
der von den Amerikanern 9 Monate nach
dem Einmarsch festgenommen wurde doch
statt Freiheit brachten die Amerikaner
Leid und Chaos statt einem geeinten Irak
feuerte die Invasion die konfessionelle
Spaltung noch mehr an religiöse
Minderheiten wie die Christen wurden
angegriffen und verlassen bis heute in
Scharen das Land
Violet Isak eine der wenigen die
geblieben ist bezeichnet den Anschlag
auf ihre Kirche als Schock
[Musik]
das war normal nach dem Krieg nach dem
Fall von Bagdad es wurden aber nicht nur
Kirchen in die Luft gesprengt auch
Moscheen es gab Angriffe auf Moslems und
Christen
es entstand ein Sicherheitsvakuum diese
blutigen Jahre haben die Menschen
geprägt bis heute
wenn man das Haus verließ musste man
ständig Angst haben dass es jeden Moment
eine Explosion geben könnte man hatte
Angst um sein Leben seine Familie das
bedeutet psychologischer
stressed herrschten die sunnitischen
Moslems heute sind es die Schiiten die
das Sagen haben und der Iran der immer
mehr Einfluss nimmt ein ständiger Kampf
der gewaltbereite Milizen hervorbrachte
er hat Traditionen und Kultur zerstört
dieser Krieg hat so viel zerstört
das Nationalmuseum wurde zu Kriegsbeginn
geplündert das kulturelle Erbe des Irak
verloren
17.000 gestohlene Objekte sind
inzwischen zurück das Museum wieder zum
Leben erweckt
natürlich hoffen wir dass wir alle
Objekte wieder zurückbekommen eine ganze
Abteilung arbeitet daran mit Gottes
Hilfe hoffen wir das Beste und so hoffen
die Menschen im Irak ihre Identität
irgendwann wieder zurückzubekommen
im Irak mit seinem hoffnungslos
zersplitterten politsystem hoffen Sie in
den USA sind die tiefen politischen
Wunden die dieser Krieg schlug auch
aktuell zu erleben und den Moskau trifft
heute Chinas starker Mann ein und gibt
sich als Friedensstifter
morgen hat er viele Gespräche dort wir
werden dann ausführlich berichten
natürlich aber jetzt heute erstmal noch
mal Johanna Rentnerinnen und Rentner in
Deutschland werden ab dem 1 Juli mehr
Geld bekommen das hat
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil mitgeteilt in
Westdeutschland beträgt der Anstieg 4,39
Prozent im Osten werden die Renten um
5,86 Prozent angehoben durch die
Erhöhung gelten dann in Ost-
die Bundesbank erwartet für das erste
Quartal des Jahres erneut einen Rückgang
der Wirtschaftsleistung in Deutschland
dieser dürfte jedoch weniger stark
ausfallen als Ende 2022 als er minus 0,4
Prozent betrug das geht aus dem
Monatsbericht der Notenbank hervor singt
das Bruttoinlandsprodukt zwei Quartale
in Folge gilt dies als technische
Rezession
Familien sehen sich wegen gestiegener
Preise und infolge der corona-pandemie
immer mehr belastet das geht aus dem
neuen familienbarometer hervor das
Bundesfamilienministerin Paus heute
vorgestellt hat demnach gaben 70 Prozent
der Eltern im Dezember an dass sie die
Inflation persönlich stark belaste knapp
die Hälfte fühlte sich durch die
Preissteigerungen im Alltag stark
eingeschränkt nur 43 Prozent der Eltern
bewerteten ihre wirtschaftliche Lage als
positiv
so das war unser Montag im heute journal
war viel los danke Ihnen für Ihr
Interesse und auch der Hinweis auf unser
heute journal Update mit Nazan göktem
Uhr was darf künstliche Intelligenz das
ist ein Thema dazu ein Gespräch mit der
ki-expertin Tina Klüver von uns allen
hier auch den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hinter den Kameras ein angenehmer Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend astrologischer
Frühlingsbeginn 22 Uhr
und wir haben auch ein kleines
Frühlingshoch das sieht allerdings schon
morgen ostwärts ab und dann kommt ein
neues Tief heran mit seiner Kaltfront
das bringt Regen mit und das ist
eigentlich ganz gut denn die Vegetation
ist ihrer Zeit fast 15 Tage voraus was
jetzt die Pflanzen dringend brauchen ist
Regen das nächste Tief sehen Sie schon
über Großbritannien heute Nacht beginnt
es also hier im Nordwesten kräftiger zu
regnen sonst regnet es nur leicht und im
Süden ist es zum Teil auch klar da
bindet sich Nebel das wird eine meist
milde Nacht Temperaturen sinken auf 9
Grad am Niederrhein bis vier Grad an der
Ostsee und nur Richtung Oberpfalz
zwischen dem Allgäu und dem Breisgau
wird es mit 3 bis 0 Grad kälter morgen
gibt's ein sehr deutliches Süd
nordgefälle bei den Temperaturen im
Süden klettern die Werte auf 16 bis 18
Grad im Norden bleibt es bei 10 bis 14
Grad deutlich frischer denn besonders
über den Norden ziehen die Regenwolken
hinweg bereits mittags erreichen Sie die
Lübecker Bucht den Harz und den
Thüringer Wald im Süden der gegen D ist
es deutlicher zum Teil richtige sonnig
am Mittwoch gibt's dann eine kurze
Regenpause wenn nämlich das tief in ihr
ostwärts abzieht aber schon schnell
kommen Hilmar 2 und Hilmar 1 hinterher
so wird das eine eher regnerische Woche
bei uns wechselhaft also ist es in den
nächsten Tagen zu nächste Nordwesten
später dann auch Richtung Südosten bei
recht milden Temperaturen zwischen 10
und 19 Grad